Kim Kardashian confirms baby number four
is on the way are you working on another
child we are that's the mother of three
made the announcement on Mondays watch
what happens live with Andy Cohen we do
is it it's sometime soon Wow yeah you
know if it's a boy or a girl
we do it's a boy earlier this month a
source told et the kardashian-west
family was in fact expanding something
Kim has discussed in our recent
interviews I'd love to tell you talked
about how st. just loves little babies
and it's like a little brother for Saint
yes I mean you know it would be nice
it really would but I'm very full right
now holy how am I gonna do three kids
I'm really freaking out what has been
the adjustment sort of going through
this with a surrogate this time I think
it's definitely a different experience
and I'm blessed that I'm able to do this
and that technology is the way that it
is that we can do this the Kardashian
sisters were fearless answering lots of
tough questions on the late-night show
they covered their love lives past and
present a Kourtney there are rumors that
you are terrified of Scott Disick
proposing to Sophia Richie's yes what
would be your reaction if they got
engaged congratulations
who was your least favorite of Kim's
exes Humphries
if you were Chloe would you have stayed
with Tristan don't I think I would
really well I don't know that I will you
stuck with Scott there a lot yeah and I
think that that's our when you have a
family like you do everything you can
for your family they also gave us an
update on their various public feuds
still a beef with Taylor after all that
went down knows all right where do you
guys stand with blac Chyna today in a
lawsuit Kayla rod wants to know if
you're speaking to Caitlyn Jenner yeah
we saw her on Christmas Eve I know I'm
around Christmas Day it's like New Year
and drama-free
you
[Music]